correspondent à des véritables images
traumatique pour des cerveaux encore
vierge immature dans leur développement
neuronal incapable d'analyser et prendre
du recul face aux images observer la
sexualité qui étaient auparavant source
de saine curiosité infantile devient
après ce premier contact objet de dégoût
et de fascination en même temps choqué
et plein de questionnements l'enfant est
amené à revenir regarder de nouveau le
contenu pornographique afin de pouvoir
l'interpréter et le comprendre avant
même que le jeune fasse l'expérience de
son corps de ses pulsions et d'une
sexualité réel en contact avec un vrai
autres il fait l'expérience d'une
sexualité qui correspond plutôt à du
sexe dur violent où la femme est un
objet de consommation apprendre à jeter
ou les dimensions constitutives d'une
sexualité saine tels que l'intimité la
confiance l'affectivité le respect et le
consentement sont absolument absente ce
contact précoce on peut le nommer
violent psychique car il envahit de
manière inattendue mais brutale un la
pensée et l'imaginaire de l'enfant et
devient un des plus puissants facteurs
de risque pour le développement d'une
addiction à partir de l'adolescence
lorsque vous le savez l'accès internet
est sans limites le smartphone dans la
poche et d'autres variables
psychologiques personnelles et
contextuelle influence les difficultés
des régulation émotionnelle et
pulsionnelle du jeune en effet à
l'arrivée de la puberté avec le réveil
des pulsions sexuelles les jeunes ont
pour beaucoup d'entre eux eut déjà accès
à ces contenus et vont avoir tendance à
l'épreuve replonger afin de se réguler
et de répondre dans le secret au désir
sexuel pas encore contrôlés souvent
envahissant lors de cette première étape
charnière du développement psycho sexuel
l'adulte en devenir se construit nourrie
par les schémas et la logique
pornographiques
95% des patients que j'accompagne dans
mes consultations disent avoir débuté
leur consommation avant les 12 ans tous
ce sujet se souviennent de ces premières
images
tel que comme me disait un adulte un
patient adulte des photos répugnantes
qui ne s'effaceront plus jamais de ma
mémoire en effet la pornographie laisse
des traces mnésiques dans le cerveau un
jeune aussi adolescent de 16 ans avec
une grave addiction me disait madame
j'ai un stock de ces images sales qui me
pollue la tête et je n'arrive plus à les
enlever
[Musique]